SUNDAR PICHAI:
Welcome to Google I/O.
For someone like me, who
grew up without a phone,
I can distinctly remember how
gaining access to technology
can make a difference
in your lives.
That's why we've been
so focused on bringing
digital skills to
communities around the world.
We've trained over
25 million people,
and we expect that number
to rise over 60 million
in the next five years.
Health care is one of
the most important fields
AI is going to transform.
We announced our work
on diabetic retinopathy
and we used deep learning
to help doctors diagnose it.
We can predict
the five year risk
of you having an adverse
cardiovascular event, heart
attack or strokes.
We have been working
with our partners
using de-identified
medical records.
Turns out, if you go and
analyze over 100,000 data
points per patient, more
than any single doctor could
analyze, we can actually
quantitatively predict
the chance of readmission
24 to 48 hours earlier
than traditional methods.
It gives doctors
more time to act.
We are bringing another feature
to G-mail: smart compose.
We use machine learning to
start suggesting phrases for you
as you type.
All you need to do is to hit
Tab and keep order completing.
Another product
is Google Photos.
We are bringing a new feature.
If you took a picture
of a document which
you want to save
for later, we can
recognize, convert
the document to PDF
and make it much easier
for you to use later.
Or if you happen to have a
very special memory, something
in black and white, we can
recreate that moment in color
and make that moment even
more real and special.
And we are adding, as
of today, six new voices
to the Google Assistant.
John Legend's voice will
be coming later this year
so that you can get
responses like this.
JOHN LEGENDS: At 10
AM you have an event
called Google I/O keynote.
Then at 1:00 PM you
have margaritas.
Have a wonderful day.
SUNDAR PICHAI: I'm looking
forward to 1:00 PM.
SPEAKER 2: Today
the Assistant is
available on over
500 million devices.
Now by the end of this
year the Assistant
will support 30 languages and
be available in 80 countries.
But one step that
we've been working on
is something we
call Pretty Please.
SPEAKER 3: Hey, Google.
Talk to [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 4: Daddy, you
forgot to say please.
SPEAKER 5: Tell me
a story, please.
ASSISTANT: Thanks
for asking so nicely.
You're very polite.
SPEAKER 6: I know.
SPEAKER 2: So the Assistant
understands and responds
to positive conversation
with polite reinforcement.
SPEAKER 7: Now
sometimes the Assistant
can actually be more helpful by
having a lower visual profile.
So let's say I'm
heading home from work,
I have Google Maps
showing me the fastest
route during rush hour traffic.
Hey, Google.
Send Nick my ETA and
play some hip hop.
ASSISTANT: OK.
Letting Nick know
you're 20 minutes away,
and check out this hip hop
music station on YouTube.
SUNDAR PICHAI:
Let's say you want
to ask Google to make
your haircut appointment.
So what you're going to
hear is the Google Assistant
actually calling a
real salon to schedule
an appointment for you.
[RINGING]
That was a real
call you just heard.
The amazing thing
is the Assistant
can actually understand the
nuances of conversation.
We've been working on this
technology for many years.
It's called Google Duplex.
It brings together
all our investments
over the years in natural
language understanding,
deep learning, text to speech.
I'm really excited to
announce the new Google News.
TRYSTAN UPSTILL: With
the new Google News,
we set out to help
you do three things.
First, keep up with the
news you care about.
Second, understand
the full story.
And finally, enjoy and
support the sources you love.
Our AI constantly reads the
fire hose of the web for you.
The millions of articles,
videos, podcasts and comments
being published every minute,
and assembles the key things
you need to know.
We're also excited to
introduce a new visual format
we call Newscasts.
You're not going to see
these in any other news app.
Newscast give me an easy
way to get the basics
and decide where I want
to dive in more deeply.
Full Coverage is an
invitation to learn more.
It gives a complete
picture of a story
in terms of how
it's being reported
from a variety of sources
and a variety of formats.
This is by far the most
powerful feature of the app.
And here in the
Newstand section,
it's easy to find and follow
the sources I already love
and browse and
discover new ones.
And if there's a publication
I want to subscribe to,
we make it dead simple.
Because you're signed in
with your Google account,
you're set.
We're rolling out on
Android, iOS and the web
in 127 countries starting today.
SPEAKER 8: Growth of Android
over the last 10 years
has helped fuel the
shift in computing
from desktop to mobile.
[INAUDIBLE] mention, AI is
going to profoundly change
industries.
And this brings me
to the new version
of Android we're working on.
Android P.
Adaptive battery uses
on-device machine
learning to figure
out which apps
you'll use in the next few
hours and which you won't use
until later, if at all today.
With Android P, we're going
to beyond simply predicting
the next app to launch to
predicting the next action you
want to take.
We call this
feature App Actions.
What's happening here is that
the actions are being predicted
based on my usage patterns.
The phone is adapting
to me and trying
to help me get to my
next task more quickly.
Slices are a new
API for developers
to define interactive
snippets of their app UI.
That can be surfaced in
different places in the OS.
With ML Kit, you
get on-device APIs
to text recognition, face
detection, image labeling
and a lot more.
And ML Kit also
supports the ability
to tap into Google's cloud
based ML technologies.
SPEAKER 9: Our team has heard
so many stories from people
who are trying to find the
right balance with technology.
One of the first
things we focused on
was helping you
understand your habits.
Android P will show you
a dashboard of how you're
spending time on your device.
As you saw earlier, you
can see how much time you
spent in apps, how
many times you've
unlocked your device today and
how many notifications you've
received.
Android P lets you set
time limits on apps
and will nudge you when
you're close to your limit
that it's time to
do something else.
If you turn your phone
over on the table,
it automatically enters
do not disturb so you
can focus on being present.
No pings, vibrations,
or other distractions.
You can tell the
Google Assistant
what time you aim to go to bed.
And when that time
arrives it will switch on
do not disturb and
fade the screen
to grayscale, which is far
less stimulating for the brain
and can help you
set the phone down.
Well, today we're
announcing Android P Beta.
SPEAKER 10: Maps was
built to assist everyone.
We've mapped over 220
countries and territories
and put hundreds of millions
of businesses and places
on the map.
We're adding a new tab
to maps called For You.
It's designed to
tell you what you
need to know about the
neighborhoods you care about.
New places that are
opening, what's trending now
and personal recommendations.
We've created a score
called Your Match
to help you find more
places that you'll love.
Your Match uses machine learning
to combine what Google knows
about hundreds and millions
of places with the information
that I've added.
SPEAKER 11: Let me paint
a familiar picture.
Your phone says, head
south on Market Street.
One problem: you have no
idea which way is south.
So you look down at
the phone, you're
looking at that
blue dot on the map,
and you're starting
to walk to see if it's
moving in the same direction.
Our team's have been
working really hard
to combine the power of the
camera, the computer vision,
with Street View and Maps to
re-imagine walking navigation.
So here's how it could
look like in Google Maps.
Notice that you
also see the map,
so that way you stay oriented.
You can start to
see nearby places,
so you see what's around you.
Now with smart
text selection you
can now connect the words
you see with the answers
and actions you need.
So you can do things like copy
and paste from the real world
directly into your phone.
You're at your friend's
place, you check out
this trendy looking
lamp, and you
want to know things
that match that style.
And now Lens can help you.
You open the camera
and you start
to see Lens surface proactively,
all the information instantly.
And it even anchors that
information to the things
that you see.
SPEAKER 12: Waymo
is the only company
in the world with a fleet
of fully self-driving cars,
with no one in the driver's
seat, on public roads.
So Phoenix will
be the first stop
for Waymo's driverless
transportation service, which
is launching later this year.
Soon everyone will be able
to call Waymo using our app
and a fully
self-driving car will
pull up, with no one
in the driver's seat,
to whisk them away
to their destination.
SPEAKER 10: And I hope you
all find some inspiration
in the next few days
to keep building
good things for everyone.
Thank you.
SUNDAR PICHAI: This
came to my attention.
We restored the natural laws
of physics, so all is well.
We can get back to business.